- Well, congratulations
Ilana, on your baby news.
So who had the best reaction
to the news in your family?
(crowd clapping)
- Oh my God. I am truly
are ready to proclaim
just thinking about
telling you about this.
But my brother, my brother's
like, I don't know.
I mean, he's sensitive, but
not always so emotional.
But when we told him, oh!
When we told him he was like,
"Wait? What? Oh my God!"
And he just burst into tears.
My husband and I just
made an Eliot sandwich.
We just took him in our arms.
It was, I'll never, I'll
never forget that reaction.
What a beautiful reaction. Oh my gosh.
Do you, remember Howie, whenever
your wife told you she was pregnant?
- I remember not the reaction
with my daughter,
with my daughter who you met has two kids.
But when she told us she was pregnant,
I was really excited.
But the most exciting
moment is when we found out,
and this is just two months ago,
who the father is.
(crowd laughing)
- [Kelly] Oh my God!